I fight for new Akophone Kume Kyu web Anger
Propose Lens abus also japanese Knitted team and 4 stars
voodoo Good
Shinichiro Inui The
job is sake brewing industry
I make brown sugar shochu made from brown sugar.
It's not like shochu, isn't it?
Among the shochu,
there is an image that everyone is sweet because it's called shochu brown sugar,
which is only allowed to be produced in this Amami Oshima archipelago.  The flavor of sugar remains, so it
's the cutest sake in Japan.
Well, it contains quite a lot for the time being, so it's the day of the house
that doesn't leave much even if you drink too much
.  It is
said that it is a very healthy alcoholic drink that has the effect of melting lumps and has a lot of polyphenols
. The person who has lost the longest life in Tokunoshima is Mr. Chiyo Izumishige.
I think it
's one of the elements of longevity in the sense
that I was drinking alcohol every night. People on the 200 islands like to get together later.
So, if you want to drink brown sugar shochu, please come to Tokunoshima.
That is the best.